after white's next move we will surpass
the world record yeah
you're ready we're ready to celebrate
i wish i had some champagne for you guys
okay can we just get champagne in here
just for the hell of it we need a couple
of bottles each
okay so just for this occasion this has
been move 124 by both players and now
white is about to make a move one two
five and that will be a new record for
title matches world breaking record you
guys the
most moves ever played in a world
championship match
here it is on the board and they've been
playing for now
uh seven and a half hours these two it's
a very long day to play chess
is it
do you see a chance of especially danyan
making an error
definitely
i mean simon and i we're still unsure i
think whether white has
i mean sufficient winning chances but
definitely in practical terms over the
board i think all the chances in the
world uh those pawns will match forward
eventually and magnus is trying to tire
out jan before that happens i mean i'm
trying to work out why this is a draw
and the only thing i can think of is
that at some point when you push the
pawns forwards they can't protect your
king as well it's because at the moment
white's using those pawns to block the
check but when they get very near to
queening the black queen can get around
behind
behind and have many checks but
for a human even this if this is a table
based draw even if this is a draw it's
so
hard
to to to find those right checks at the
right time um so
if i was a gambling man which clearly
i'm not
you never would um i i probably
you back white i don't i don't i give
well 60
55 60 for white to win this left behind
so you have to be careful which white
pawn you push either way it's time for
that moment cheers you guys cheers 135
years of world championship history we
have a world record today cheers to
everyone and cheers to the viewers i
guess
nice
um more than seven and a half hours now
playing this game giving everything to
us all their blood sweat exactly just in
this one game yeah and uh meanwhile
magnus has put his rook on an outpost
defended by porn he's getting ready to
march the white king forward white pawns
will still will soon start to
push as well i've been trying to figure
out what is the best configuration for
the king and the knight and the rook
just because when you do advance the
pawns you want your king to be in the
safest square i mean how far up the
board can the king go the white king
that is it's difficult i think as soon
as the white king goes to the side of
the board now the black queen will swing
across and trap it on the side of the
board the white king wants to kind of be
semi in the center but not quite
um i think it just wants to stop the
black queen getting close to it
so uh okay magnus first just giving a
check
he's happily just
stacking up those moves racking up the
move count and uh remember the last
capture was on move 115.
so
he's done nothing for twelve moves but
the guys just hang around far too much
together
you really do it's just like you know i
bet you me and magnus yeah yeah i bet
you but you have jokes you're like
madness if you get a chance
try to get to 200 moves all right dave
i'll do it just for you and it's like
yeah i i can exclusively exclusively
reveal that when i played a 143 move
game recently he did message afterwards
so he was watching right so he's going
he's definitely trying to beat him
what did he say david um he said
something about good stamina old man i
think
[Laughter]
but uh
he's right it's not easy for sure the
stamina and
players remember there's a game tomorrow
they will be feeling it tomorrow as well
so it's not about putting
not just about putting the pontiac under
pressure now it's about putting him
under pressure over the next 24 hours
will a long game like this break the
routine
um for me no it's just an average uh
average friday but
actually for sure it will break the
routine um
yeah i mean he won't be able to prepare
tonight he's lost a few hours where he
could be studying openings he's lost a
few hours where he could just be hanging
out having dinner with his friends
with his team yeah of course it breaks
magnus's routine as well but
maybe he thinks it's worth it
and uh okay another check another king
move
and the black king all the way back to
its starting square
move 129 and the black king is back
where it started the game wow actually
quite nice this drink by the way yeah it
was so bad
and sugar it was just perfect give me
some sugar yeah wow
so that means 179 now yeah all right
but it means the magnus doesn't
necessarily want to break the world
record otherwise he would have waited to
move 160
well okay so how could we see this game
end at some point how could it end
what is magnus trying to do obviously
get his pawns over to the other side
when will he give up what will have him
give up i think the only way magnus will
ever give up this one is if black
achieves perpetual check which means
checking forever and white's king being
unable to escape those checks
or the position repeating itself three
times
or maybe the 50 move rule i don't think
magnus will offer a draw unless there's
really no chances left anymore no no
he's going to try every single thing um
i suppose again we've talked about why
this might be a draw
and white's pieces are going up the
board
and at some point they just have to go
all the way up the board and that will
leave the white king very exposed to
checks from behind
at the moment they kind of cover things
more but the further they get up the
more checks that black has but
i think if you get the right
configuration of pieces then then you
can still win this one definitely so
it's uh
it's uh really well i mean maybe 50 50
is is a fair result i mean between a
draw and a win i i keep changing my mind
but
i don't know what i mean david what do
you think yeah chances are yeah the
inclined to agree i think the winning
chances for magnus are just as good as
the the likelihood he'll end in the draw
and uh there we go the black queen
pinning the white rook but white's king
is going to move again and we're going
to go round and round in circles for a
while and then another white pawn will
push later on and look at that in honor
of the new world record chess 24 premium
is having a flash sale so you can now
get 50 off just 24 premium membership
and remember they do have this new very
very very cool play zone on chess24 so
that is a great
um
sale to join in on flash sale 50 on
chess24 that is the code to use i told
you guys chas is the winner today
everyone's a winner at home
celebrating this
bargain and i heard if you are an
arbiter you get chess 24 all the chess
ball course is free because of my
insults
i don't want to say i feel really bad
now there's so many great arbiters out
there um and he just trashed
i only trash the percentage of them most
of most of you are lovely so next time
i'm playing the tournament
just go easy on me please um you know
first round black pieces second round
black pieces third round no i love
arbiters really in the bar now
is that the highest it's been all game
for magnus white is definitely making
some serious progress yeah i think it
might be uh there was one move i think
just before mu 40 where magnus had a
huge opportunity but since then this is
maybe the best position he's had
and
notice he's going forward on every turn
earlier the white pawn push forward now
the white king is stepped as far forward
as possible and the white knight yes
it's on the edge of the board but it's
acting as a shield for the white king
and
yeah we talk about progress in end games
but just kind of achieving a goal a
small mini goal and then moving on to
the next goal and magnus is achieving it
step by step so yeah for sure the
computer might say it's still a draw but
the ponyta is going to start getting
there and it seems like black's queen is
on the wrong side of the board here yeah
it needs to be yeah i mean what's it's
going to get it's going to be running
out of oxygen in this area of the board
so i'm sure it will switch back around
to to uh to come behind or something and
according to cesa it's winning for right
wow so just before this last movie seven
what was this okay the queen stepped
back attacking the white rook why why is
it going this way i don't understand it
that's
the bar what's happening is magnus
winning he's winning yeah he can
actually push his pawn forward leave the
white rook attacked and this would be
winning pretty much instantly the
computer says checkmate in 38
but i think it's going to be actually
easier than that wow look at this
stockfish confirms white has one move
that's much better than all the others
and magnus has just leaned forward i
think he spotted it this is not obvious
this is not easy for a human your rook
is attacked you want to defend it or
move it
but you can actually leave that rook
where it is and that move wins
can we show it
so if you push the pawn um it leaves the
rook on pre but why can't black take
that rook david ah so the pawn the queen
attacking the rook if the pawn matches
forward queen takes rook is met by a
night fork knights are the trickiest
pieces in chess this is a check and next
move you win the black queen and uh yeah
as long as you have one pawn left in
this type of situation to become a queen
later you win the game a knight on its
own wouldn't win but this pawn would
work what an opportunity he's got two
minutes two minutes to find it is he
going to find it this
pawn push yeah we should mention rook to
f6 so just moving the rook to safety is
also strong so maybe that's going to
tempt magnus it's a safer option but
this one would pretty much win the game
because actually black is just tied down
black and barely do anything if you move
the king there's a nasty check and the
white the black queen drops as well um
if you check then actually white has a
variety of moves you can even just
sidestep and the same idea if queen
takes pawn so enough so what if black
tries i think black's put the queen on
the wrong square the black queen is
running out of oxygen because it's too
near the white pieces so what if white
tries to swing it
over has he played it has he played the
winning move he's played
in the picture is he noticing this
okay
oh he's frowning he's lent forward
he's he's trying to keep a poker face
but he knows he's in big trouble now
the russian is about to go down after
all of that defense after defending
successfully for 130 moves he put his
queen on the wrong square on the wrong
circuit and it's game over almost
unbelievable this is what pressure does
this is what this ongoing attack does
and magnus is just pressure pressure
pressure pressure and focus now look at
him and total focus he realizes here uh
i mean i still don't quite see it if the
queen comes all the way over to a7 to
win but i'm trying to work it out now
but it's just the white king in advance
and and he can advance safely with no
checks right and uh that is a big issue
yeah wow
yeah yeah yeah okay
it's going to come and give a check
wow
so this this is going to be the round
forgot what round round six six round
six win that that happens
so often in the world championships and
it's it's this is going to be such a
blow for jan let's remember yam was
winning this game he was winning this
game and he's this is going to be
horrendous for him to lose this yeah
that's horrendous after almost
heartbreaking eight hours as well and
he's got two more games to play before
the rest day
and he's spending a lot of time now
ticking under one and a half minutes
to save this game and simon i've got to
give you credit you called it a long
time ago despite the computer saying 0.0
for 50 60 moves you said practical
chances is so easy for white to play
it's so easy for black to blunder and
magnus he did nothing for so many moves
but when he started pushing forward he
allowed the pony actually to go wrong
and the pogba actually failed to find
the right hand and he's only got a
minute left now but uh i mean as if
magnus finds the right moves he will win
this game and is that hard is it hard
for magnus to be accurate in this
situation could still go wrong here oh
no really
he can move his rook to the f7 square
you could move your rook two squares
forward remember if the black queen
takes this pawn in the center
gotta find this move if he [ __ ] if he
finds it he wins yeah
which one does he have to find he has to
find the rook moving up two squares and
uh then the knight will come in and give
a check i mean he saw the original
tactically winning king opponent yeah if
you take the exactly if magnus picks up
his rook and moves it two squares
forward he's winning look at the bar
18.5 for the world champion massive and
has he done it has he done it he's found
it he's played it wow he's done it well
look at that look at the bar willian and
pogba actually resign now just keep an
eye on the players
i think he's going to resign he can't
decide let's get both players in the
picture to see what happens now and but
what else can he do white's knight next
move is just going to go up to check and
then the white pawn is going to march
forward and make a new queen yeah that
pawn's coming eddie eddie the eagle has
gonna land on e8 here and
one one line here is if you take the
pawn it's very close to being a draw but
there's only going to be one pawn
remaining and that pawn is the winning
pawn uh we'll show this a bit later
that's crazy yeah of course you can't go
away from the players right now but this
is crazy this variation how long has
this gone on for this is increasing
seven hours and 45 minutes
134 more wow unbelievable crazy i mean
okay this is
power he's trying he's trying anything
he can now okay he's moved his king
across one square so but maybe just pawn
on
e7 doesn't that win well hang on then
the king can run to the e8 square so
maybe it's knight check knight or six
check yeah but then king takes rook king
takes knight and it's not ah over yet so
you can still mess it up if you're
called simon yeah but if you call magnus
you probably won't yeah but look at this
okay it has another pawn in his pocket
right they much forward together
torturous we talked about the pawns the
rook the knight all of them now
combining in harmony together and next
move the white pawn is going to step up
check against the black king and white's
going to make a new queen it's game over
now
wow i hope for napoli actually look at
magnus as well in his face he knows it
he knows he's got it he's clinched
unbelievable i mean you can tell that
you know you should never relax until
it's over but he's just taken a bit of a
side there and this is uh and it's just
been an incredible game and in that
classic magnus crawls in fashion as well
people have
questioned his motivation is he still
the same and he plays for seven hours
and 45 minutes
everyone's saying this is a draw and he
clinches it yeah yeah
this last move is so classy i've got to
say by magnus he's allowing checks but
he's going to run with the white king
all the way in front of the white knight
he's going to march his king the whole
way up the border to sit in front of the
white knight
and no more checks and the white pawn
will be the new queen beautiful
beautiful
final touch so so sophisticated
no stalemates nothing question for you
both is this the type of loss that is
maybe going to cause yan and pognashi to
tilt to crumble yeah i think this is
because it's devastating you know
who would not be upset after this this
is incredible you're winning you were
drawing it's a long game you're tired
you played really well
i mean this this could crush
a lot of people it's gonna be so
interesting to see in the next two days
now tomorrow yeah and sunday yeah we
have our first win there we go we have
it we have a handshake
the first decided game and we hear
applause from dubai magnus carlson the
world champion
in game six that always ends up with
drama and he wins it and they actually
talk about it